jose gregoria licarre is disheartened as
he shows us a video of his home
destroyed and clashes between the
venezuelan army and a colombian rebel
group
it's really sad seeing how easy it is to
lose everything you've built
with great sacrifice he and his family
fled a week ago
from a town across the border as
venezuelan soldiers moved into their
neighborhood and bombs fell
from the sky they left in such a hurry
that he didn't have time to put shoes on
he is one of almost 5 000 people who
have sought refuge in one of the 18
shelters set up in and around the border
town of araukita in colombia
they've come here after the venezuelan
army started
an unprecedented operation against
colombian armed groups they had long
tolerated in their territory many are
accusing security forces of abuses
and in at least one case of
extrajudicial killings
i'm afraid of going back to venezuela
because i don't know what they would do
to us
the soldier killed our neighbor her kids
and her husband they say we're all
guerrillas
the influx of refugees many young
children
is overwhelming this town on sunday the
colombian government set up a command
post
to manage the worsening humanitarian
situation with the help of the united
nations refugee
agency and other organizations
the priority is the humanitarian
assistance of those who entered the
country to guarantee their health
food and hopefully guarantee a swift
return
the colombian government is planning for
the shelters to operate for at least two
weeks
even if local venezuelan authorities
said on saturday that people could go
back
despite assurances from the venezuelan
government that the situation is under
control
we heard more explosions coming from the
other side
just a few hours earlier and more people
are arriving fleeing from venezuela into
colombia eight days into this crisis
the situation is very difficult this man
says
there is no food we don't know what we
will do
back at the shelter most people say
there are no guarantees for a safe
return
for now jose gregorio is happy he and
his family
at least have food and a shared roof
over their heads
alessandro rampietti al jazeera araukita